this is the turnip sandwich like Little
John when he brought turn down for what
he wrote it based off of this sandwich
this looks good I've never heard of fat
sandwiches before sounds like the best
sandwich ever
better be stacked right I feel like it's
one of those sandwiches where you should
not eat it like in public I had some
pepto-bismol before this to prep my
stomach smells like bread oh [ __ ] I lost
a fry already it's like the breads
breaking it can't handle the sandwich
they've put all the good things in the
world until one sandwich our students at
Rutgers fatter than the average
University student on their drinker
oh then that this makes sense I want to
be drunker is what I kind of want I
would like to be drunk this is so good
this is missing cheese it is missing
cheese there's a mozzarella stick those
mozzarella stick disguises chicken
should we just like inhale it and miss
it don't use my sauce it really needs
more sauce
I'm already full thank God you had that
marinara sauce with you I mean I don't
go anywhere without it if a friend wants
to have heartburn for the next seven or
eight hours I would definitely recommend
this and everything I'm gonna do it when
10 out of 10 would eat again it changed
my life forever I ate it I liked it but
that's gonna give me a heart attack they
deserve the name fat sandwich private
affair I made her talk driving my
sandwich
yeah yes it was everything like mmm king
maharaja tastes